hey everyone welcome to this video on
cyber security interview questions part
5.
this is the final part of the cyber
security interview question series
and here we will focus on the popular
cryptography questions that can be asked
in a cyber security interview
our experienced instructor bipin will
take you through these questions
so let's get started but before we begin
make sure to subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update from simplylearn
the first question define cryptography
encryption
and decryption now cryptography
is used by security professionals to
scramble data
into non-readable format which is used
in securing that information
so it involves converting data from a
readable format into a non-readable
format
and then reversing it back to readable
format again
for example the word computer is now
scrambled
into looking like an unreadable format
now if you look at this word that it has
been scrambled into
it would be very difficult for a human
to figure out what the actual world was
now in this scenario we have taken an
algorithm where we have made a
shift of the alphabet where we have
added two alphabets the current one so
c plus 2 becomes e o plus 2
becomes q m plus 2 becomes o so we have
done a shift
of 2 and thus the key over here for this
algorithm is the alphabet plus two so
any person who
figures that out will be able to
unscramble this and convert this back
into readable text
the fact of scrambling a readable text
data into something that is unreadable
by using a particular key
is what cryptography is all about now
as we discussed the decryption again is
replacing the alphabet
and taking it further back by two
characters
so e minus two becomes c q minus 2
becomes o
o minus 2 becomes m and so on so forth
so anybody who knows this key
the shift key anybody will able to
decrypt this particular character so
this depends on the user if i want to
utilize
alphabet plus five then the spacing the
shifting of that character
will be the fifth character from that
particular character
and so on so forth the next question
what is the difference between cipher
text and clear text
cipher text refers to the text which is
encrypted and totally undesirable
the message received after decryption is
known as clear text this text is
comprehensible
so the word computer is clear text that
means that it has not been treated to
any cryptographic measures
it does what it is intended to be
however
if the moment we encrypt it that means
we scramble it into unreadable text
by using any of the algorithms that
we'll be looking at
that text is known as a cipher text and
without the key this becomes
unreadable the clear text as discussed
is the plain word that we have utilized
we are using the english language in
this instance
so the plain word computer is the clear
text once we add the encryption layer to
it
we get the cipher text to it
moving on to the next question what is a
block cipher
this refers to the method of encrypting
the plain message
block by block the plain message is
broken down into fixed size blocks and
then encrypted
now a block cipher is normally used for
data
that is stored so a data that is stored
on a hard disk and we want to encrypt
that data
that is known as block encryption or a
block cipher so a block cipher
is an algorithm that will allow you to
encrypt
data that is stored onto a hard disk so
in this example
we've got plain text which is 64 bits in
size
and we have added a layer of encryption
to it so plain text plus the key that we
have studied in the previous questions
and then the scrambled data out of it
which is unreadable
and thus encrypted then the next
question what is public key
infrastructure
now the public key infrastructure is a
set of policies which secures the
communication between a server and a
client it uses two cryptographic keys
public and private
so the infrastructure itself is a set of
policies people procedures and
techniques
which are standardized in nature and are
globally accepted
which allow us to use digital
certificates
to encrypt data and decrypt the data
at the other end we use asymmetric
encryption over here which means that we
are used two keys
one is a public key to encrypt and the
private key to decrypt
the other part of the encryption is a
symmetric encryption where the same key
is used to encrypt and the same key is
used to decrypt
now in a public key infrastructure
uh like i said we have standardized that
so insta in the standardizing part of it
these are the various players that have
been defined in the public key
infrastructure
the first is this user or the sender in
this scenario the one who requires
this digital signature to digitally sign
a particular transaction or a
communication
a registration authority with whom they
are going to register for that
particular key
the certification authority who issues
that key the verification
authority who validates the key itself
and the recipient who is going to be the
other party of that particular
transaction
so how is this utilized a sender or the
user who requires this
digital signature will request or apply
for a digital signature with the
registration authority
the registration authority would
validate the
genuinely of the user so they might do
some
identity verification or
proof of residence or something like
that once they've identified the
person and they have validated the
information
they will then send the request to the
certification authority
stating that the sender has been
validated and we can
and the certification authority can
issue the digital certificate
to the particular user they will
send the public key to the sender which
will be utilized by the sender
for further transactions so when the
sender
is going to sign some data and wants to
send it across to the recipient they
will use the public key to sign it
and send it across the recipient will
then
validate with the verification authority
to see if the data
the signed data is correct or not now
while the certification authority sends
the public key to the sender
the certification authority updates the
private key with the verification
authority so whatever is signed by the
sender uh received by the recipient and
they want to validate it they will send
it back to the verification authority
the verification authority will validate
using the private key
once the private key is validated it
will then send
the okay signal back to the recipient
thus allowing the
validation of that particular
transaction
if the signature is tampered with or is
not the
very fiction authority is not able to
validate the signature it will then send
a denial
message back to the recipient and the
transaction will
not go through so the pka enables
trusted digital identities for people
so the pki grants secure access to
digital resources based on the
infrastructure that has been created
and the core of the pki is a
certification authority which ensures
that the trustworthiness of the digital
data is
ensured so going back to the previous
slide
these are the key players that have been
standardized in the
public key infrastructure the
certification authority is the authority
that issues the digital certificates
the validation authority is the one who
validates that digital certificate
moving on what is rsa
rsa is one of the first public key
crypto systems that is used for
secure data transmission it stands for
reverse xiaomi and adelman
now these are the three people who have
created this algorithm
randy west adishamir and leonard edelman
who are the inventors of this technique
it is a symmetric cryptography algorithm
which works on both public and private
keys
hence the encryption key is public and
the decryption key is kept
private now as we have discussed earlier
symmetric and asymmetric cryptography
symmetric cryptography is where the same
key is used to
encrypt and decrypt whereas asymmetric
cryptography is where there are two keys
to encrypt and decrypt the algorithm
what are the few alternatives to rsa now
rsa is an algorithm
that is used for encryption there are a
lot of other algorithms that can be
utilized
to alter or to scramble data depending
on your requirements
so in the previous question we have
studied and we have talked about what
rsa is it stands for uh reverse xiaomi
and edelman the three creators
of that particular algorithm but there
are a lot of alternatives
to this algorithm depending on how
secure you want that data to be
and some of them are listed here on your
screen
duo security octa google authenticator
and
lastpass lastpass is a password manager
so is duo security google authenticate
is something that we all utilize it is
an application
that we can download and store on our
mobile devices and we can set that up
to authenticate ourselves with certain
portals
so it issues a unique id to us
which once utilized will allow us access
to those particular portals
octa is an identity manager where you
have created different digital
identities
and you have assigned them certain
permissions and
based on your authentication mechanisms
octa will allow or disallow
access to those different applications
or different portals as you have
configured it so all four are
authorization authentication mechanisms
which can be used as alternatives to rsa
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description
to know more next question what are the
prime objectives of modern cryptography
and this is a very important question
because we've so far looked at what
cryptography is
and what public key infrastructure is
but what is the achievement out of it
why are we utilizing it
and what do we want to gain out of it
so the main and the prime objectives of
modern cryptography are
as follows mentioned on your screen the
first one is confidentiality
the second one is non-repudiation third
one is authenticity
and the fourth one is integrity now if i
go back to the first one confidentiality
uh that is where i want to keep data
confidential
that means it will only be visible to
the authorized users
right so here i've created a list of
people who have
deemed as authorized users and have
created a digital identity to them
and have given access controls to those
people now that is how confidentiality
is
ensured so when we want to keep data
confidential we create a list of users
who we are going to allow access to
certain resources
and we are going to define what access
controls are to be utilized what access
are allowed whether they
got an administrative access or user
level access and only those authorized
users
are going to be able to access these
resources that is how we maintain
confidentiality the next one is
non-repudiation non-reputation is the
prevention of denial of having been a
part of a particular transaction
so in the public key infrastructure that
we discussed where a digital signature
was utilized to sign
a particular transaction and then sent
to the recipient
the sender would not be able to deny of
having
originated that transaction because it
was using their
digital certificate thus non-reputation
comes into the picture
uh one more example that we can have
here is
on our mobile phones when we use sms
short messaging service
and we send a message to uh to another
person
the person when they receive a message
the number is validated by the service
operator
and thus the sender cannot deny having
sent that message the sender at the same
time can have a delivery report sent to
them
uh from that the message was delivered
to the inbox of the recipient
and thus if the recipient denies having
received that message that delivery
report
becomes proof of having that message
being delivered to their inbox
thus both the parties cannot deny of
have a
of being a part of that particular
transaction
then comes the part of authenticity
now in confidentiality we have created a
digital identity assigned it to a
particular person
and we have given them digital
signatures where they cannot deny having
been a part of that transaction
but authenticity is the part where they
try to prove that they are who they
claim to be
so if i am claiming a digital identity i
have to
prove that i am that person who i'm who
i'm trying to claim to be
and an example to that is when we go to
our gmail.com websites
it first asks us what is our username
our username is normally our email
address
which identifies the account that we are
trying to access
right so this account is confidential
because it is only authorized for a
particular person
and once they identify themselves by
identifying the email address
that's when the authentication part
comes into the picture where it asks for
the password
now it has never ever happened that we
just go on to the gmail.com type in a
password
and then it figures out which account we
are talking about so the first step is
always
the confidentiality part where we
identify which account we are talking
about
and then we try to authenticate as the
owner of that particular account
by providing the appropriate password to
that account
if both of these match only then do we
get access
to that account and we are able to
make uh whatever transactions we want to
make now when we are making those
transactions not reputation comes into
the place
where all our activities also being
logged so we have
identified our account we have
authenticated ourselves by providing the
password
so the proof is there that it is us who
are trying to access it
and then whatever activity we do send an
email receive an email delete
something attach something all of those
activities are logged
and stored as proof of what actions have
been done
so tomorrow if we deny having sent that
email gmail can still prove to us
through those logs that though that that
activity was done by us
and the fourth part is integrity which
ensures that the data received and sent
and
sent by the sender and received by the
recipient has not been modified
while in motion
so the integrity part is the
trustworthiness of that data that the
data has not been modified by any hacker
or any other
entity and is still trustworthy so these
are the four prime objectives of modern
cryptography once i have scrambled that
data
using my public's uh signature
it is only my private signature that is
going to decrypt it right
using these mechanisms i will be able to
achieve all these four aspects
of cryptography and security next
question
what is safer now safer stands for
secure and fast encryption routine
which is also a block cipher as we have
discussed previously
block cipher is a cipher that is used to
encrypt data that is stored
so it has a 64-bit block size and byte
oriented algorithm
ciphers encryption and decryption
procedures are highly secure this
technology is widely used in
applications like digital payment
card so when you are using your a
digital
payment gateway to make transactions so
you have you have gone on to an online
portal
you want to purchase a particular item
and
then it takes you to another payment
gateway where you have to fill in your
credit card information sensitive
information like your
uh expiry dates cvv information
and then the otp or the password that
you have created for your particular
account now all of these need to be
secured
or highly secured based on pci dss which
is the payment card industry data
security standard
so these standards ensure that certain
protocols are utilized
to attain that level of security safer
is one of those block ciphers
that is used under the digital payment
gateway infrastructure
next question how does the public
infrastructure public key infrastructure
work
now we have already discussed this in
the previous diagrams
we have identified the key players the
certification authority
the registration authority the end user
who requires the digital certificate
the validation authority who's going to
validate it and then
the recipe and the end user with whom
the
transaction is going to be conducted so
the first point here is
the request for the digital certificate
is sent to the registration authority
they validate it and then they okay to
the certification authority who then
process the request and the digital
certificate is issued to the person who
has requested it
so when the person wants to conduct that
transaction they use that
uh digital certificate to sign that
transaction with the end user
the end user validates that with the
validation authority
and once validated the transaction goes
through
and now the last question what is the
blowfish algorithm
it is a 64-bit symmetric encryption
algorithm so this is an algorithm that
uses the same key
to encrypt and the same key to decrypt
the same secret key is used to encrypt
and decrypt the messages
here the operations are based on
exclusive ors
and additions to on 32-bit words the key
has a maximum length of 448 bits
now this is a little bit technical uh
you might not want to go this technical
in a in an interview question you just
need to identify what the algorithm is
used for
so whether it is a symmetric algorithm
which means it uses the same key
or uh a symmetric algorithm where it
uses
a public key to encrypt and apply
private key to decrypt
thus the blowfish algorithm is just one
more algorithm which uses symmetric
encryption
to encrypt and decrypt data algorithms
that we have seen
rsa and others that we have discussed as
far as the interview questions are
concerned what we need to remember
is uh which algorithms are symmetric
which algorithms are asymmetric
what do symmetric algorithms do and what
do unsymmetric uh symmetric algorithms
do
and we also look at block ciphers and
stream ciphers
block ciphers are utilized to encrypt
data that is stored
stationary data data at rest and stream
ciphers
are utilized for data in motion while
they're being streamed
so ssl and tls is another algorithm that
comes into the picture
when you're looking at streaming data
and with that we have come to the end of
the cyber security interview questions
part 5 on cryptography
i hope it was informative and
interesting if you have any questions
related to the topics that were covered
in this video
please ask away in the comment section
below our team will help you solve your
queries
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here